hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and Alyssa be
crazy today we're checking out those us
teaser trailer for Zootopia from Walt
Disney Animation let's check this out
she loves Disney so here we go hot in
here super hot too hot in the world of
Zootopia humans never happen
which makes utopia a modern civilized
world that is entirely lower animals
yeah isn't it
animals you have or anthropomorphic that
is just a big fancy word means they walk
around on two feet they do not go to
work nude thank you
almost jason bateman that's got it
nothing was technology
okay there are menus from all over the
globe in Zootopia largest fat fast and
slow butter shrimp is she joking isn't
perfect and just like our world and
everyone gets along especially natural
enemies racism which can create some
issues but nature always gives animal
special skills to survive it while one
may have amazing my vision another may
haven't failed at hearing and an
air-powered
elephant tranquilizer so now you know
Zootopia like nothing you've seen honey
I never you say wow actually looks
really cute it looks really adorable I
do like the concept of the world my one
I mean yeah it's cool and all animals
evolve and they pretty much were able to
do everything humans are able to
accomplish but I would have been a
little more interested in seeing a world
that was not like that with just a bunch
of animals what do you mean I don't know
I'm just looking at nature so just
watching animals like well you know I
never saw like that it's better what
they went with it's better what they
went with yeah I mean you could just
turn on Animal Planet or like Meerkat
Manor and you just watch meerkats drama
go down I like this concept it's a good
an learn something new I kept amorphic
you know that's just a Disney word
either way that's the thing too and I'm
pretty sure it's a real word I don't
think so pretty positive what's the word
isn't it like an orphan I don't know if
there's a paean area something do more
picking you don't even know what the
word is go back do that ain't going back
we've lost this conversation oh no I
want to see the word I was right
whatever
yeah okay you learned any work but jason
bateman he has some of the best dry
delivery it's cool scene and being part
of it
made a film it's a cool concept and you
know it's the guys who did big hero 6 so
you know it's like something bomb it
excites me and raise me a little bit
that I mean of course it's Disney frozen
but I really would not like there to be
another song like let it go
that'll take over the world again they
go have you think they'll be musical
numbers in this I don't mean this I know
so big hero 6 didn't have any I mean
there I bet music but not like singing
dancing yeah exactly
oh you have a point yeah so you don't
know Alisa don't speak out of your ass
I'm just making an observation that it's
Disney and they tend to do that you know
it's true anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you need to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Alyssa's
channel Elissa be mad I mean be curry
crazy notes Alyssa be mad one day you're
gonna just get it put into Anna st.
Asylum and you're just gonna have a
smile on your face that never breaks and
that's just going to be you frozen yeah
you're a vegetable stuff like that and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and by because if we get enough
followers we can get product placements
for things such as watermelons
watermelons are great they are
nutritious
they detox you hence they make you poop
a lot actually high in fiber and you
know I like pooping I know you do I
really like poop and very well well well
wear that you like to poop you know
every time I go to your place you know
like when a dog pees on a place to claim
its territory I poop in everyone's home
I know to unite sure we like to poop
apologize leave skid marks I know all
over the toilet
I know on the seat I know sometimes in
the sink I know one has to clean it up I
know I don't know and you know what
helps you to accomplish all that
watermelons they make you poop this is a
PSA brought to you by Ryan